das wäre also könnte ich mir vorstellen
dass ich mich mal kurz patentieren ich
mache meine eigene schokolade
bevor es losgeht kanal abonnieren
blogger aktivieren jeden tag 19 uhr
gibt's neues video typs scud ab und
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video jahn hatte ich hoffe natürlich
geht es gut eigentlich wollte das habe
ich auch schon letztmals hilfe ich finde
irgendwie immer viel besser wenn das
video mit kameramann gedreht wird vor
allem so ein video
aber der ist im urlaub jetzt ist der
kühlschrank laut na ja auf jeden fall
gibt es heute den vierten part meines
formates ich teste alle sorten davon von
diesem produkt aus dem supermarkt minute
hatte ich jetzt mal ein bisschen namen
ich teste alle sorten eines produktes
aus dem supermarkt irgendwie so ihr habt
mir vielleicht in den kommentaren
vorschläge geben letztes mal hatten wir
schokopudding übrigens habe ich es
richtig gefeiert ich kriege andauern
weil instagram so fotos oder sowie
abends auf der couch liegt und euch
diesen pullin reinpfeift der bei mir auf
platz eins gelandet ist also im letzten
video zum beispiel oder was weiß ich auf
jeden fall habe ich sehr oft in den
kommentaren gelesen braucht kommentar
alex machen wir alle milka sorten macht
darin ranking und gucken welche die am
besten schmeckt und ich war heute morgen
einkaufen
ich hab mal wieder an der kasse ich
glaube noch nie hat jemand zuvor alle
mega sorten gekauft weil das sind nicht
so 10 oder so das waren 30
was ist das denn
ich glaube 27 fans also vor mir liegen
gerade 27
mika sorten ich habe mich aber eben
wirklich schon gefragt nimmst du das
video in einem stück auf oder macht eine
pause oder machst du sogar zwei teile
weil wenn ich von jedem hier ein stück
selbst neueste habe ich danach 1
eins zwei drei vier fünf mal eben ganze
zwei tafeln verdrückt alter als ihm ein
video von gestern gesehen habe wo ich
auf die ansage reagiert habe sie ist aus
wir haben nochmal sport gebe aus seiner
wohnung der machbar sport denke du
siehst gut aus glaubt der ex treppe nur
auf ich glaube der hat recht nahe und
also werdet merken aber ich das auf
teile die auch immer also hier haben wir
einmal alle so hatten 27 stück mit der
hier ich weiß nicht vielleicht gibt es
auch noch mehr auf jeden fall da wo ich
war gab es heute 27 das hier ist die
vollmilchschokolade kennt ja glaub ich
jeder die musik gar nicht probieren da
weiß ich wie die schmeckt und die ist
echt geil
deswegen würde ich immer so als staat
kandidat nehmen und sie mache ich das
denn eigentlich hier kommt hier an die
seite bekommt von mir gut 10 von 10
also ich habe auch schon mal bessere
schokolade gegessen deswegen würde ich
sagen acht von zehn punkte das ist also
praktisch unser staat heute und dann
machen auch direkt weiter hier haben wir
im märz vater alpenmilch schokolade weil
ich noch nie gesehen und auch noch nie
probiert also ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen ich mache mir jetzt wirklich
ungern zwei tafeln rheinberg mithin der
letzte wirklich wichtiger für köln schon
reicht auf der zunge zergehen lässt um
den vollen geschmack war abzunehmen also
wir haben hier auf jeden fall dunkle
schokolade
ich muss sagen ich persönlich bin jetzt
nicht so mega der fan davon trotzdem
ergänzt sich das mit dem himbeer ganz
gut habe ich jetzt sich umgibt von mir
sieben von zehn punkte position dahinter
und eure aufgabe ist natürlich auch
weiterhin irgendwelche produkte in den
kommentaren zu schreiben die halt in der
nächsten folge dran kommen sollen das
ist sehr wichtig weil dieses format
passt sich auf jeden fall euren wünschen
und ich würde auch eigentlich nur das
machen was ihr mini kommentare schreibt
interessant das habe ich glaub ich auch
noch ein komet kub
ich kenne mich heißt das jetzt hier ist
diese dieses einzige top drinnen okay
das ist ja echt druck da passt doch gar
nicht erwarten also da muss ich sagen
das passt meiner meinung nach nicht so
gut zusammen ist jetzt zwar auch nicht
schlecht aber ist jetzt nichts wo ich
sage okay das übertrifft all meine
erwartungen ich sag mal so würde ich
nicht nochmal kaufen deswegen gibt es
auch noch 15
wir machen so dass sie hat ihrer acht
punkte das hatte sieben wir starten das
einfach das kommt darunter das hat als
nächstes haben wir orio tokio habe ich
noch nie probiert bin ich mal gespannt
ok in folge sorgten glauben auf diesem
video ist mir sowas von schlecht ist gut
allerdings irgendwie ein bisschen zu
mächtig so ich weiß nicht das schmeckt
so kassen ab so kohler also ist ja auch
schokolade aber versteht ihr wie ich
meinen kriegt von mir sieben von zehn
punkte und 30 auf hinter der alpen bin
ich ein abkommen gibt es denn loriot
sandwich die habe ich noch nie gesehen
genau die andere hab ich schon mal
gesehen aber nicht probiert jetzt bin
ich mal gespannt ob die besser oder
schlechter geht auf jeden fall meist aus
wenn man sich das hier so anguckt also
optisch auf jeden fall eine 10 von 10
mussten wir schon finden wollen
schreibt mir gerne eure
lieblingsschokolade von milka in die
kommentare
die hier war voll in ordnung ich fand ja
auf jeden fall besser als die roro
variante davor dinge zu mir absolut zehn
punkte
leute die hier kenne ich muss ich jetzt
trotzdem probieren ist eine gute frage
kommt drauf an otto haselnuss verein
bist oder nicht oder ob - allerdings
oder nicht war das jetzt einfach so
durch 7 15
ich bin jetzt nicht so denn lust werden
darum nichts ohren nicht schon wieder
eine datenbank mit zarter alpenmilch das
wird wirklich schwierig ich nehme
einfach mal auf die hälfte von der
hälfte weil sonst das nicht durchziehen
die ist echt lecker sich richtig gut
warum warum auch immer mir die so gut
schmeckt soll ich ja eben schon gesagt
habe ich mag eigentlich so zart bitte
nicht ganz so gerne die irgendwie schon
ok als nächstes kommen wir zu joghurt
habe ich glaube ich auch schon mal
gegessen
früher so weiß ich noch zur schule
gegangen bin war neben anderen
supermarkt und manchmal einer freistunde
habe ich mir so joghurt schokolade gut
ich hatte mal so eine zeit da war ich
fand ich das volk also habe ich noch nie
gemacht also die sehen eigentlich gleich
aus oder hey hier sehen komplett warte
mal das können die sonne alpenmilch
creme und jung und die war einfach zu
faul ein neues design zu kreieren guck
mal das einzig
was anders ist es ja klecks hier drunter
interessant alex ist ja auch irgendwie
blöd das wird schon zähne haben zehn von
zehn geil joghurt beste also ich bin ein
richtiger joghurt freund heißt nächstes
haben wir alpenmilch cremen
das problem ist auch ich kann das gar
nicht mehr so richtig genießen einfach
weil zu viel des guten ist auch nicht
gut da waren die augen haben ja größer
ist der magen und ich habe gerade mal
acht von 27
wie ist hier nochmal alpenmilch creme ja
auch lecker schmeckt irgendwie ähnlich
also zumindest da ist so leichter
kältehoch dabei war steht ihr wenn da so
irgendwie so junge drin ist oder ist
jetzt wirklich zu erklären was ich mit
kalter hauch meine vielleicht versteht
ihr ist haut mich nicht komplett um
wieder joghurt deswegen gibt es acht von
zehn ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen also
auch mal ein dankeschön an euch
das ist wirklich viele leute von meinen
zuschauern gibt die die videos feiern wo
ich hier sitze irgendwelche sachen
probieren und die von eins bis zehn
minuten und dann auch noch das beste
selber nachkaufen also das ist auch
nicht selbstverständlich dankeschön
was haben wir jetzt noch satte prozente
gazette methode das echt leid aber ich
glaube ich bin nach spätestens 15
komplett raus und die schmerzt schon
schmeckt sehr nach nuss ist mir leider
wieder ein bisschen zu nutze ich
deswegen gibt es hier genau sieben von
zehn als nächstes kuhflecken die wird
doch einfach genau zu schmecken die
alpenmilch oder mit bisschen weiße
schokolade zwischen es gibt auch keine
sorte die es nicht gibt anfangen jetzt
irgendwas einfallen würde ach guck mal
das würde auch bestimmen sollte guckst
du ins regal gibt's schon immer eine
idee habe ich an die marketingabteilung
macht doch mal eine schokolade
kollaboration mit haribo meinetwegen wo
ihr und dann packt ihr diese kleinen
haribo bären in die schokolade
das wird also könnte ich mir vorstellen
dass ich mich mal kurz patentieren und
ich mache meine eigene schokolade heute
geht man auf den instagram account von
milka und schreibt alex hat eine kasse
idee sehr gut so krass ist er jetzt auch
nicht schmeckt genauso wie die
alpenmilch variante keine ahnung warum
man so was dann auch noch aus bringt
vielleicht weil es ganz cool aussieht
aber
weil es genauso schmeckt muss ich das
jetzt einfach schlechter bewerten und
bewährte ist mit sechs von zehn
jetzt kommt es schon wieder so eine
schokoladen bomba schüttelt kakao der
schokolade frau die skate das ist auf
jeden fall der zehn prozent oder
karamell ich bin ein absoluter karamell
fans ich kann nicht mehr ich kann echt
ich mich kümmern wie viel wir haben eine
haselnuss herd nuss für ist habe ich
noch nie
wir machen einen kleinen kompromiss die
beiden probiere ich jetzt noch da muss
ich erst mal eine pause machen
fangen wir hiermit an erdnuss christ
aber mal gespannt
also das sind jetzt wirklichkeit
erdnüsse drin also man muss auf jeden
fall sagen der geschmack der schokolade
übergibt man schmeckt die er müsste
eigentlich gar nicht mehr so ein ganz
kleines bisschen aber ich glaube wird
man sie mehr schnecken wird es halt auch
überhaupt nicht passen so gummibärchen
und schokolade feierlich eigentlich dass
hier wiederum eher nicht deswegen gibt
es auch hier sechs von zehn und zu guter
letzt dann gibt es erst mal eine kleine
pause karamell oder passt nur auf bitten
den floor mouthaan hatte ich irgendwie
besser eine änderung hat so einen kaffee
haltigen abgang
komisch war das eine andere schokolade
die ich mit karamell genau habe ich
verwechselt die hier bekommt erstmal
19.30 dann hier ein und das was ich
meinte war bei diesen diese box wo so
ganz viele verschiedene bambergs drin
sind davon dass karabel dem celebrations
oder wie die heißen dass aber ich muss
jetzt erstmal eine pause einlegen
ihr seht schon schlecht ich weiß ich
muss mal gucken ich habe die vermutung
das video wird schon 15 minuten oder so
deswegen vielleicht machen wir dann
daraus noch einen zweiten part nimmt es
mir nicht übel für ist ja zurzeit führt
auf jeden fall joghurt und ganz unten
ist doch scheiß absolut rein finde ich
und joghurt ist an der spitze ciao